bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 13 juin
des têtes d'affiché des découvertes pour
sa saison 2018 2019 le prisme vise une
future pour tous c'est aussi la première
saison entièrement programmé pour la
ville d'elancourt
certains artistes on t'appelle quatre
ans à la ferme du mousseau l'école
d'arts plastiques expose les oeuvres de
ses élèves une réflexion sur la
métamorphose et des grands formats pour
ne rien rater d'un paysage d'un lieu où
d'un instant les 16 10 et 17 juin
prochains le festival panoramique
revient à villepreux trois lieux
d'exposition permettront d'admirer les
clichés pour débuter ces magazines
culture on prend la direction du prisme
à elancourt la salle de spectacle nous
révèle sa programmation au choix du rire
du jazz au corps du théâtre patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images
quarante quatre rendez vous du 12
octobre au 24 mai le prix ce modèle en
cours proposent une culture pour tous
pour sa nouvelle saison
allons voir sa programmation
[Musique]
virgin et voir son bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes la nouvelle directrice du
prisme et pour cette saison 2018-2019
c'est assez éclectique il ya de tout
théâtre des concerts dans la continuité
du travail réalisé au prisme depuis des
années on est sur une programmation
voilà qui propose à la fois du théâtre
de la musique de la danse pour toutes
les tranches d'âge et tous les publics
la culture pour tous tout à fait c'est
de toute façon credo de
de cette nouvelle programmation et tous
les arénas et qu'un projet aussi tel
qu'il a été imaginé dès le départ on est
dans cette facilité de travail car chez
vous la saison débute le 12 octobre et
c'est un duo qui monte
oui elles reviennent d'une tournée de
deux ans à l'international et b17 sont
deux soeurs à la musique très métissée
oui ebayi deux soeurs jumelles puisqu'il
signifie également
jumelles en langue yoruba et la langue
en fait des esclaves noirs déplacer à
cuba ce sont les deux filles d'un
percussionniste du buena vista social
club
on peut de ligré intéressant et en fait
elle d'une connu voilà une carrière
assez fulgurante premier album en 2015
d'une tournée mondiale des parrainages
voilà comme prinze donc voilà une
trajectoire assez improbable elles sont
sûres un métissage musical entre la soul
electro les musiques traditionnelles à
elles sortent un deuxième album file en
sortie d'ailleurs déjà qui s'intitulait
h
donc on les accueille dans le cadre de
cette nouvelle tournée et puis elles
viennent au prisme donc pour l'ouverture
de saison ce sera le premier spectacle
de la saison
en configuration ou grande salle assis
debout puisque on est sur des concerts
musiques actuelles plutôt festif avec la
possibilité aussi des traces humainement
[Musique]
dans votre programmation il ya aussi des
têtes d'affiché on pourra bla toutes les
cités avec général elektriks eric
métayer lionnel astier frédéric bouraly
qu'on connaît surtout sur une sur une
série manu payet
arthur ashe c'est pareil on ouvre large
oui on ouvre large et dans tous les
champs artistiques puisqu'à la fois aux
musiques actuelles on vient de l'évoquer
avec ribéry arthur ashe je pense que
voilà beaucoup le connaissent avec un
dixième album qui est assez merveilleux
qui s'intitule amour chien flou double
album dédié à l'amour sous toutes ses
formes
on accueillera également mon cas saison
prochaine j'ai plus tout à fait les
dates en tête mais voilà vous avez
exactement
arthur ashe dans le champ du théâtre
donc vous l'avez cité eric métayer la
leçon de danse mais aussi avec mais
payant de la baisse contre damas qu'on a
tant fait un très beau les chatouille
les chatouilles voilà au préalable effet
voilà une adaptation d'un polar il a
parfois de vendre et abriteront et puis
là on est dans un registre est différent
une comédie romantique sensible une ode
à l'humanité de personnalités
complètement improbable qu'ils vont se
croiser une danseuse blessé un
scientifique aussi autiste qui ne
supporte pas qu'on me touche
et puis voilà on se croisait pour une
leçon de danse et voilà de ça va naître
voilà une relation assez incroyable
voilà pour ce spectacle
et puis après dans le champ de l'humour
effectivement une programmation très
variée avec des grands noms du one man
show françois xavier demaison manu payet
voilà et alex vizorek
chroniqueur lui à france inter donc et
qui lâche marc de la culture qui parle
de la culture existe un questionneur
renard qui propose du coup à la fois de
vous cultiver tout en vous en passer un
agréable moment sont des sommes
résolument contemporaine d'aujourd'hui
et on pas plus loin parce qu'il ya des
classiques revisités comme le
misanthrope chez vous c'est le 20
novembre
voilà alors un misanthrope versus ou
version nuancée version politique alors
c'est aussi vous le disiez les
classiques
alors on est sûr sur du molière qui se
prête très souvent en fait à une contre
eux contextualisations monde
contemporain sont déçus ce sont des
textes d'une extrême modernité en fait
et c'est le cas avec voilà ce
misanthrope qui s'adapte
particulièrement bien voilà ça se passe
dans un cabinet politique voilà auprès
d'un seul actions si tu es un changement
de ministre et puis voilà tout
l'aéropage du personnel qui est en train
d'évoluer les conflits d'intérêts et
puis notre alceste au milieu de tout ça
qui est voile absolument tiraillé par
son souci de d'intransigeance de droite
est donnée de thé où tous les
ingrédients sont réunis pour refaire
vivre ce texte de molière dans voilà une
époque très contemporaine on aura aussi
un menteur de corneille là c'est un
texte un peu moins connus s'était pas
partie des plus monté de l'automne bon
classique grain mise en scène de julien
zidi une relecture très vitaminé aussi
transposé avec des éléments en tout cas
qui sont du monde contemporain à la fois
pas on est sur des choses qui se qui se
croisent l'époque se mêlent
et puis on y parle du mensonge et
l'utilisation d'une mensonges notamment
aux une société qui ne jurent que par
l'image avec une mise en scène et une
scénographie assez incroyable voilà tout
un jeu de miroirs au plateau c'est un
très joli spectacle
on a conseil de musique on va refaire un
petit mozart musique parce que le prise
aussi c'est le jazz
il ya des rendez vous c'est pas oublier
et à pires heures et les piano bars
alors j'étais petit instant aussi avant
le spectacle il ya eu effectivement un
très très grand nombre de rendez vous
dédié au jazz sous toutes ses formes
toutes ses couleurs parce que ça fait
partie des esthétiques musicales qui
sont extrêmement ouverte voilà sur sur
différents courants et puis nous on a
différents formats aussi pour permettre
aux spectateurs de vivre ces moments là
les api or tous les jeudis en dehors des
vacances scolaires avec une
programmation alors là je vais parler de
versions touchard voilà qui est notre
directeur artistique pour la
programmation jazz plein qui en tout cas
sur tous ces petits formats là qui
sélectionne des groupes issus de
diverses
horizons et avec des sensibilités
artistiques différentes c'est tous les
jeudis à boire un peu lignes haute et
quelque chose au bar du théâtre tout en
appréciant une programmation qui
changent pas toutes les semaines
voilà les piano bars qui sont opposés
avant les représentations du spectacle
donc là avec un un groupe résidents dont
vincent fait partie on n'est plus du
coup sûr une ambiance musicale fort
appréciable des dias passion il y en a
quatre dans l'année et vincent a
travaillé cette année autour de la
thématique du métissage dont vous
découvrirez voilà sur ces quatre rendez
vous à musicaux qui sont en petite salle
c'est pareil du coup toute la pluralité
et la richesse de ce que le jazz peut
avoir à offrir
et puis en grande salle voilà des des
têtes d'affiché 1000 parisien vincent
peirani
donc il y aura de quoi satisfaire les
oreilles les plus exigeantes
on a donné beaucoup de rendez-vous mais
ce qu'il y à un spectacle à ne pas rater
votre coup de coeur peut-être alors oui
c'est vrai que
et c'est notamment eux qui ont fait la
mise en espace de la soirée
d'orientation de saison hier la
compagnie de technal à qui j'ai un
attachement particulier puisque je les
connais bien
avec les spectacles sosie on est un peu
dans l'écriture de l'émission
strip-tease pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent voilà on devrait se dresser
des portraits personnage assez
improbable atypique puis là c'est un
trio donc pour ce spectacle un trio de
le personnage qui serait ni pour créer
un spectacle de sosies michel berger
céline dion et francis cabrel
et le spectacle repose en fait sur l'
équilibre entre du cynisme beaucoup
d'humour noir et puis une vraie
sensibilité c'est à dire que passer la
première approche qu'on peut avoir ou on
peut être tenté de vraiment rire de ces
personnages là on voit il ya une
sensibilité qui est qui est offerte à
découvrir c'est un très joli spectacle
vraiment en écriture contemporaine
écriture collective au plateau koné
merci bienvenue mars ont alors pour
découvrir toute la programmation et
réservez vos billets direction kiosque
pause qui point fr et cette saison et la
première programmée par la ville
d'elancourt depuis le 1er janvier la
commune gère l'équipement la maison pour
tous qui comprend notamment la salle de
spectacle des précisions avec laurent
mazaury maire adjoint en charge de la
culture
c'est une première dans la continuité
puisque la volonté de la ville
d'elancourt
ça a été bien entendu de maintenir
l'offre culturelle et la programmation
dans sa philosophie telle qu'elle
existait depuis des années avec succès
mais de venir y rajouter un ensemble de
nouveaux éléments plus ouvert j'ai à
dire d'une programmation passerelle de
façon à faire que eh bien cela réponde à
plus d'attendre d'un nouveau public et
que de nouveaux clients élan courtois
consommateurs de culture passionné de
culture et le courage de pousser la
porte du prisme être spectateurs et
artistes pendant une année scolaire 13
classes saint-quentinoise ont participé
à la 19e édition de danse à l'école
un parcours d'éducation artistique et
culturelle piloté par le prisme et saint
quentin en yvelines samedi 9 juin ils
ont restitué leur travail les images
sont signer nicolas dans de riches
[Musique]
150 enfants réunis sur le parvis du
prisme et un flash mob pour lancer les
festivités
il montre au public le travail de toute
une année scolaire danse à l'école il ya
plusieurs classes sur l'agglo où il ya
des artistes qui viennent dans les
classes et qu'ils proposent
une sensibilisation à la danse
contemporaine on leur apprend à être
libres émancipées à avoir le regard
critique et à être capable d'inventer
c'est un projet en direction des jeunes
du territoire de saint quentin
porté par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines temps dans lequel
des jeunes gens on va dire de la grande
section de maternelle au lycée découvre
le plaisir de partager la danse avec les
autres dans leur classe c'est très
important avec des danseurs
professionnels
[Musique]
huit artistes danseurs ont été
sollicités cette année danse à l'école
leur fait découvrir le rôle de
spectateur mais aussi d'artistes grâce à
des ateliers ont rien à faire est il
dans sa pourrait s'étirer
s'entraîner et
c'est un peureux lac comme ça qui te
sens bien là chapeau à ma fille on a
fait du groupe e après on se rencontre
et on faisait on faisait des vans ce que
tu peux apprendre des nouveaux
mouvements
je connais delvaux est tu peux connaître
de nouveau personne des danseuses et des
danseurs
cette année treize classes et 380 élèves
ont participé à cette 19ème édition
qu'est ce que la métamorphose le fil
rouge de l'exposition annuelle des
élèves de l'école municipale d'arts
plastiques d'elancourt
cette année 150 élèves ont choisi une
oeuvre à présenter elles sont toutes
rassemblées à la ferme du mousseau
sortir de l'atelier de l'enseignement
exposer son oeuvre regard de l'autre
avec graine d'artiste les élèves de
l'école municipale d'arts plastiques
présente une création réalisée au cours
de l'année globalement le travail qu'il
choisit c'est un travail quand même que
eux estiment assez aboutis et justement
cette question de l'aboutissement c'est
quelque chose qu'on travaille aussi avec
avec les élèves que les enseignants
travaillent avec les élèves
c'est à dire c'est aussi le regard
apprendre à l'élève a regardé son
travail sculptures peintures dessins et
arts plastiques
plus de 150 oeuvres autour d'un même
thème celui de la métamorphose une
transformation de matière d'objets
d'époque pour trompé l'oeil du
spectateur
l'idée avec ce fil rouge de la
métamorphose c'est de proposer un
un cadre un cadre d'action qui leur
permettent de s'exprimer sur la notion
de transformation
évidemment la métamorphose en arts
plastiques
c'est assez courant quelque chose qu'on
pratique de manière assez naturelle
puisqu'on est déjà dans la
transformation de la matière
la métamorphose aller d'une part dans
l'intention de l'artiste dans
l'intention de celui qui pratique mais
elle peut être aussi dans le regard de
celui qui voit le qui voit le travail
graines d'artistes et comme une
rétrospective de l'année écoulée
un premier pas sous les projecteurs pour
ces artistes dont les plus jeunes ont
seulement quatre ans
ils seront près de 300 sur scène c'est
saint quentinois forment le coeur des
enfants des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines
ils vont vous emmener en voyage à
travers les siècles et les pays pour
vous parler d'opéra la création est
signée pierre calme les le projet est
porté par l'association de promotion de
la musique classique un mot avec hervé
charge
le président de l'apn excuse le but
c'est que chaque enfant obtienne aille
le plus haut possible de ce qu'il est
capable de faire et ensuite de le faire
ensemble entre les enfants de trappes là
pour cette année et rappelé à verrières
et langres montigny dire qu'il est
important qu'ils sont ensemble c'est un
côté lien social on a choisi les plus
grands airs des grands opéras c'est
quelque chose de fou et vous verrez au
moment du spectacle ils sont capables de
le faire
on continue ce magazine avec notre
invité gilles fait bonjour alors vous
êtes le responsable communication du vil
prix image pixels et les 16 et 17 juin
prochain vous propose un festival autour
de la photographie panoramique voilà
donc le ce week-end en fait c'est le
troisième festival de la photo
panoramique à villepreux puisque le
premier festival a eu lieu en 2014
ensuite en 2016 on le fait tous les deux
ans c'est une grosse organisation est
donc là on va présenter dans trois
salles d'angles il pr plus de 115 140
photos panoramiques
alors en fait la photo panoramique déjà
ça nous oblige les imprimés parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant avec les
téléphones et smartphones les petits
compacts beaucoup de gens prennent des
photos soit ne les regarde pas soit les
mettre sur leurs ordinateurs soient les
maîtres est vraiment sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais les avantages du panoramique pour
que ce soit vraiment intéressant il faut
l'imprimer et c'est vrai que la
photographie avant tout c'est une
impression puisque une photographie
quand l imprimé sur un beau papier donne
un autre un autre pic et comme on dit au
niveau de la photo
donc on a pour votre information on a
par exemple une photo qui va faire plus
de 7 mètres et la plus petite phrase 60
cm et en termes de technique c'est cette
une c'est un style qui le demandent
connaissances particulières un matériel
spécifique ou pas du tout alors c'est
juste un peu de savoir faire alors un
petit peu de savoir-faire oui puisque
bien sûr quand on parle de photos
panoramiques c'est pas la touche
panoramique savez on avec le smartphone
ou emballé parce que déjà un début c'est
très très bien mais là en fait l'intérêt
de la photo panoramique c'est qu'on va
assembler en fait on va prendre
plusieurs photos sur un paysage ou
autres des animaux dans la forêt peu
importe est donc en fait on va assembler
toutes ces photos de façon à avoir déjà
beaucoup plus de pixels donc une
définition beaucoup plus grande
et quand on imprime on peut voir les
détails beaucoup plus en détails qu'il
faut chercher ça attire l'oeil pour voir
d'ailleurs une photo qui sera exposée
qui s'appelle ou et gilou je vous donne
pas l'auteur je vous deviendrez ou et
gilou puisqu'en fait c'est une photo qui
a été prise sur une plage en commun
rowland et donc on peut aller chercher
justement tous ceux qui sont sur la
plage c'est très intéressant
alors les photos graphiques qui sont
présentés sont notamment celle d'un
concours elles sont pas affichés par
hasard alors effectivement on a eu plus
de 200 inscriptions à notre concours qui
a démarré déjà en 2000 fin enfin dé
cembre peu près je me décembre janvier
et donc il ya une première sélection par
un jury et donc on a sélectionné des
finalistes qui auront la joie d'être
exposé donc sur nos trois salles on en
repart à tout à l'heure et pourront
repartir puisqu'on a imprimé leur photo
et pourront partir avec leur photo donc
il y a deux jugements il ya une première
sélection en a sélectionné les 20
premiers donc il ya environ 60 photos un
petit peu moins de 60 photos puisqu'il
ya plusieurs catégories
il ya une catégorie nature une catégorie
libre pour les pour comment les adultes
et on a une caté rue catégorie pardon
jeunes voilà quand on parlait de
techniques qui en fait voilà si on est
un petit peu aidés
on peut facilement faire de la photo
panoramique et donc il faut savoir que
un des gagnants du vote du public
puisqu'il y avait un vote par dons des
internautes est un enfant de six ans et
demi il s'appelle timothée donc je le
félicite et donc il va exposer sa photo
ce week-end les 16 et 17 juin et sagem
timothée peut-être vous avez pu échanger
avec lui il apprend comment il a été
aidé par sa famille où il a déjà les
compétences techniques l'appareil
numérique l'ordinateur peut être enfin
oui l'ordinateur c'est obligatoire
puisque en fait on va faire d'ailleurs
une démonstration on va parler des
animations il ya des animations c'est à
dire on va pouvoir justement le samedi à
des ateliers et le dimanche où on peut
même venir carrément dimanche avec son
appareil photo et on va vous initier à
la photo panoramic alors effectivement
faut un ordinateur pour assembler ces
photos je crois que le papa est
informaticien donc ce qui fait que ça
aide un petit peu mais enfin il a six
ans et demi
voilà vous verrez sa photo je vous
laisse la découvrir elle est vraiment
très sympa parce que l'oeil du
photographe c'est quand même ce qui est
plus important chez un photographe est
justement vous en tant qu'organisateur
en gardant tout cela c'est un
téléspectateur cela dit moi si j'ai
envie d'en faire la photo panoramique
comment on fait des petits conseils
alors ben je dirais les ja bienvenue au
club
mais surnom mais en fait on va lui
expliquer un petit peu que c'est pas
très compliqué il suffit petites
techniques de prise de vue maintenant on
a des logiciels très facile il suffit de
mettre des photos et le c'est le
logiciel qui va travailler un petit peu
de travail de retouche mais on n'est pas
obligé non plus de faire de lagon de
retouche et très vite on sort une photo
qu'on peut voir sur un écran même en
16/9 seulement s'arrête ici et le but
lassé de l'imprimé donc là bas
maintenant il ya toulouse plein de plein
de sites où on peut imprimer largement
sa photographie à écouter non il n'y a
pas de limites puisque
voilà c'est la limite de l'imagination
si j'ose dire alors évidemment le plus
facile c'est de prendre par exemple un
paysage on veut parce que l'intérêt du
panoramique si je veux prendre par
exemple la ville de saint quentin où le
centre commercial et ben je vais pouvoir
balayer alors que sur un appareil photo
on est quand même limité donc là
l'intérêt c'est qu'on peut balayer on
peut prendre le pont de la concorde
jusqu'à la tour eiffel si on veut
puisque on a même des photos en 360
alors justement ça me incite à vous
parler de christophe grès 5 et d'autres
invités d'honneur parce que tous les
lors de tous nos festivals on a eut
commandé des invités d'honneur et cette
année c'est après arnaud frich c'est
christophe cussac et qui va faire une
conférence samedi à 15 heures la salle
annexe on va reparler des salles sur le
360 donc et technique un petit peu
spécifique là qui demande un petit peu
un niveau un petit peu plus experts mais
l'intérêt c'est qu'on peut monter les
photos il préfère ce qu'on appelle les
visites virtuelles vous savez où on
clique sur la photo et on va aller
voilà dans le château latour le jardin
de mme et on voit là donc merci c'est
fait on est un peu pris par le temps
mais bon on ne rien manquer du festival
panoramique le site va s'afficher en bas
de l'écran et je le rappelle c'est à
villepreux et c'est les 16 et 17 juin
maintenant on part à trappes à la mairie
ce qui accueillait hier soir mardi 12
juin les phases finales du 19e
championnat inter collèges de magie
d'improvisation quatre collèges étaient
en compétition et c'était le public qui
était chargé de les départager
autant sur cette soirée avec aurele
aurélie ronde des obstinés berger et
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
les championnats inter collèges de match
d'aruna seront sans les policiers
le mal est là
explosion de joie pour nathan marie
cyrine nicolas arthur et la lie ce sont
ces collégiens de coignières qui ont été
désignés par le public de la merise pour
remporter le trophée de cette 19ème
édition du cycle mythe organisé par
déclic théâtre une année de travail
récompensé on n'arrive pas à croire
première année on gagne la première fois
du coup bah c'est super et je sais pas
comment expliquer l'enthousiasmé c'est
génial gang des femmes à barbe ou encore
un navire sans avenir
durant la soirée 4 collège de trappes et
long cours montigny le bretonneux et
coignières se sont affrontés sur ces
thèmes d'improvisation pour ces phases
finales quelques règles à respecter
comme la construction de l'histoire et
le respect de la langue française à la
fin de chaque passage le public donne
son verdict pour sa première
participation le collège la mare au sol
a remporté tous les suffrages
ils viennent là avec juste la folie du
jeu est en fait du coup ils sont
complètement détachée de l'enjeu et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence
[Musique]
on a une grosse énergie vient
véritablement dans les collèges et ça
c'est vraiment très intéressant et au
delà de cette énergie de la créativité
de l'imaginaire
cette année le championnat inter
collèges d'improvisation théâtrale a
réuni 15 établissements de saint quentin
en yvelines une participation record qui
pourrait bien augmenter pour la
prochaine édition
le coup de carnets de la semaine celui
de gaël paineau du grenier à sel
tetra pour l' écoute c'est le mois de
juin c'est les vacances et la fin de
l'année alors pour fêter ça nous vous
proposons grenier à sel plusieurs
cadeaux le premier on en parle depuis
quelques temps depuis fin mars on vous a
proposé des films nous a proposé de
choisir le fait que vous voulez voir ce
sera donc ce vendredi 15 juin à 20h45 le
film qui a été élu le film qui avait
plus de votes c'est la ronde
un film français de 1150 de macau füle
max ophuls dans lequel on retrouve un
choc et d'acteurs on a donc gérard
philipe simone signoret serge reggiani
daniel gélin et cetera c'est donc ce
vendredi 15 juin mais le deuxième cadeau
et là c'est un peu une surprise c'est
une avant première d'un film que j'ai vu
que j'ai choisi que j'ai envie de vous
montrer
c'est donc l'avant première d'un film
surprise ce sera le vendredi 22 juin à
20h45
soyez curieux c'est une avant-première
donc
c'est vraiment un serment un cadeau le
film sortira plus tard je vous donne
aucun indice parce qu'avec internet on
peut trouver très facilement ce que
c'est en tout cas faites nous confiance
c'est vraiment un bon film à noter dans
vos agendas
prochainement nous avons aussi le
dernier film de notre sélection les
lumières du grenier ce sera les dents de
la mer juste avant les vacances le
vendredi 6 juillet avant de partir à la
piscine ou à la mer et nous participons
aussi au festival images vagabonde
hommage juillet on vous en dira plus un
peu plus tard à bientôt
et justement images vagabond à partir du
16 juin c'est la septième édition de ce
festival est il des buts notamment par
une avant première au ciné cette
d'elancourt
la réalisatrice les affreux de valve
présentera son long métrage les affamés
avec une certaine loi emera on regarde
un extrait de la bande annonce
quant à elle son emploi du moment ne lui
permettait pas vraiment de mettre ses
compétences à profit qu'ils ont une
capacité de concentration proche du
chaton parlons aujourd'hui je me bouge
je trouve un taff et non cacolac c'est à
ce moment là que j'ai compris les jeunes
c'est pas juste une catégorie d'âge fait
une place sociale
on nous devons tous font rien nous
donner en échange donc ils mentent pour
récurer des chiottes pour faire des
fichiers excel jusqu'à pas d'heure comme
éric yonnais faut qu'on entre en gare
on va créer une liste des choses qu'on
acceptera plus au monde charte
exactement notre objectif attaquer le
système de l'intérieur
c'est la fin de ce cette culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain
[Musique]